I'm not
Stan.
It's been a ride.
Every model.
I guess I had to go to that place.
Yeah.
You know some of you might still be in that place.
You fall trying to get out.
Yeah.
Just subscribe to me.
I'll get you there.
You can try and read these arrows off my compiler before I make them.
I don't live my coach,
so make sense that I break them.
My Algorithm,
it's dopey.
Take them when I code it,
I use pots on,
I don't give a damn if it breaks.
I'm doing this for you.
Let's hack it all.
Chatty bots and games and machine nade music.
I keep it open towards kickup do through name is source to all those who look
down on me.
Just call me.
See Rich Ology our neural next,
we'll see better than biology.
Self driving cars will drive dreams to reality.
Learning Syntax and formatting.
Also properly until we get the BSO D on Old technology.
I'm learning from my data of and deltas and dated for pushing every limit.
Right,
and Matt laughs.
Just kidding.
Matlab sucks.
Get adult kicked,
pull out,
get push,
get,
commit until you to get from new to get legit.
Pretty model
from
two to four
years
data
view.